cinéma maintenant c'est le Prix Louis
DEC qui a été attribué aujourd'hui le
laoréa c'est le metteur en scène Pierre
Granier de fer pour son film une étrange
affaire alors France Roch je crois qu'il
faudrait d'abord tout d'abord avant
toute chose rappeler l'importance du
Prix Louis DEC c'est le concours du
cinéma et c'est un prix qui a été
remporté par les plus grands metteurs en
scène certains à l'apogé de leur
carrière comme coctto ou clouso et
certains tout à fait au début de leur
carrière comme Bertrand Tavernier comme
Eric Romer ou comme Dian curis c'était
pour son premier film alors graniier de
fer lui c'estel quelun de tout à fait
confirmé oui Granier deffire il a une
carrière de 20 ans parce qu'il a
commencé exactement il y a 20 ans avec
le petit garçon de l'ascenseur et il a
fait des films extrêmement différents
des films à suspense des films policiers
des comédies des films psychologiques
mais si on devait caractériser son style
de film c'est que c'est le metteur en
scène qui a obtenu la confiance des
vodettes les plus grandes et les plus
difficiles il a fait par exemple deux
gabins la Horse et le chat il a fait
trois Signoret le chat la veuve couire
et l'étoile du Nord son dernier dernier
film il a fait trois de long la race des
seigneurs le toutbib et la veuve cou il
a fait enfin de Romy Schnider une femme
à sa fenêtre et le train alors on
pourrait peut-être demander tout de
suite à Gérard Lanvin qui joue donc dans
une étrange affaire Gérard Lanvin merci
d'être venu racontez-nous en quelques
quelques phrases l'histoire de cette
étrange affaire c'est justement ce qui
est difficile c'est de raconter ce film
en quelques phrases enfin je vais
prendre trois mots peut-être c'est un
abus de pouvoir à mon avis c'est c'est
une étrange affaire mais c'est un abus
de pouvoir c'est l'histoire d'un employé
à qui on donne deux solutions c'est de
dire oui ou non et par rapport à ça on
arrive à en le charmant en le subjuguant
aussi beaucoup à lui faire dire que oui
voilà c'est à peu près ça en fait c'est
un grand patron qui arrive dans une
affaire qu'il a décidé de lancer et qui
découvre un jeune cadre et ce jeune
cadre il arrive à l'arracher à sa
famille à sa mère et en faire
pratiquement son esclave mais alors
Gérard lenvin est-ce qu'il fait ça parce
que ce jeune homme a une espèce
d'homosexualité latente qui est révélé
parce que tout d'un coup il découvre
qu'il était un ambitieux ou parce que le
grand patron a un charisme
extraordinaire c'est une espèce de
gourou non c'est simplement parce que
c'est un charmeur tout simplement et
comme tous les charmeurs il arrive à ses
fins je veux dire à partir du moment où
il a un terrain en face de lui propice à
ça à être charmé ce qui est le cas du
personnage que j'interprète euh il
réussit à à en faire un peu non pas non
pas un esclave mais un un collaborateur
simplement un collaborateur alors nous
allons voir tout de suite un extrait de
ce film je vous propose de de voir
l'extrait France il faut rappeler quels
sont les autres comédiens Michel picoli
et puis Gérard Lanvin bien sûr et deux
autres comédiens remarquables qui sont
Jean-François Balmer et Jean-Pierre
calfon alors n voyons tout de suite un
extrait donc d'une étrange affaire de
Pierre Granier de fer prix Louis de
lu premieron à quoi
Bonin quoi vous pensez aux grandes
surfaces sachez loui que je n'ai pas
l'intention de me laisser par
les
Mamou nous av
atslacement inestimable la
diversification de produits ENF les vurs
son
prè franis signalé un peu de couage
quelques défill
[Applaudissements]
isol
nous notre travail est très simple Louis
trois phases sol de
printemps quinzaine de blanc
Noël c'est là et pas ailleurs que se
réalise notre chiffre
d'affaires et c'est là Louis que vous
intervenez envin vous avez une bonne
carrière maintenant au cinéma comment ét
comment s passé votre collaboration à
graniier de fer ah formidable c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup c'est
sentimental cette collaboration elle est
elle est elle a elle reste elle reste
complètement sentimental je ve dire
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime énormément
parce que c'est quelqu'un de simple et
de d'efficace parce qu'il est simple et
de d'extrêmement sensible et c'était
important pour moi d'avoir quelqu'un
comme Pierre pour contrôler le
personnage que j'avais à jouer je ne
crois pas me tromper en disant que en 20
ans de carrière malgré très grand film
il n'a jamais eu de prix non il n'a
jamais eu de prix je pense pas enfin je
je je connais je connais pas les
récompenses qu'on a pu lui donner
comment a-t-il réagi à ce prix est-ce
que vous l'avez vu oui et ben je l'ai vu
réagir complètement simplement en disant
tout à l'heure les prix on s'en fout
tant qu'on en a pas un et puis quand on
en a un on est content merci Gérard
Lanvin